[Musique]
c'est un phénomène important celui de la
migration des parisiens dans les
différentes régions de france des
citadins qui ont fait le choix de
rejoindre leurs parents ou de se rendre
dans leur résidence secondaire au bord
de la mer ou à la campagne pour éviter
d'être enfermés dans leur appartement de
ville sauf que voilà ces afflux massif
de citadins dans les régions françaises
ne plaisent pas à tout le monde que ce
soit à l'île de ré ou au cap ferret
cette descente massive de parisien n'est
pas vue d'un très bon oeil voiture
vandalisée tac contestataire ou colère
des riverains pour eux cette attitude
est tout simplement égoïste et
inconsciente des internautes bretons se
sont insurgés contre cet afflux de
touristes totalement irresponsable
d'aller se disperser 1 s'ils achetaient
sottise conneries aiguë [ __ ] restez
chez vous en cause des supérettes vidées
de leurs approvisionnements des plages
sur lesquelles les confiner semble
confondre quarantaine et grandes
vacances et le risque de centre
hospitalier rapidement saturés autre
point certains insinue que les parisiens
feront voyager le virus dans des régions
qui jusqu'àlors n'étaient pas contaminés
mais si certains comprennent cette
colère d'autres indiquent que maison
secondaire ou pas ils sont chez eux et
ont le droit de vivre ici à leur racisme
anti parisien comprenez vous la colère
des campagnes alors est ce que vous
comprenez la colère des campagnes rené
malleville mon chéri tu comprends pas
ben oui je les comprends parce que moi
qui suis je suis dans mon petit village
rats et la maison que dans laquelle je
suis me vient de mes parents
grands-parents arrière-grands-parents
jockey mérites de la voix mais je suis
chez moi ici et quand je vois pas ce
qu'il y'a pas que les parisiens se
dégrade de ville et ils sont pas dans
leur résidence secondaire yann actu
remous et pourra reparler là bas et
c'est les mêmes qu'il était cassé les
couilles pour le chant du coq décrit à
ceux de l'église allait battre le pôle
de mana et là mettant ça y est c'est
l'idéal
on n'est pas d'accord ouais donc ça
t'énerve voilà non mais moi je te le dis
voilà alors moi je comprends les rues
gros parce que moi j'habite à marseille
depuis 63 ans mais je suis rue issus de
la ruralité et si lampard de la partie
c'est moi ici et 73 ans que je
n'interdis l'add on en parle
il en a marre il ya le maire il me dit
rené doit au bingo il faut arrêter la
sorte que le leur le tracteur là le
corps lahrache forme et qui nous emmerde
pas alors là vous êtes retrouvé la carte
par vous attirer un peu le bonheur
plutôt que de la ville est bien là avec
ce père que cet été n'aura plus de
polémique mais tout ça voilà alors ya
une vidéo
il ya une vidéo qui a fait polémique
bien entendu c'est cette image à la gare
montparnasse au lendemain des annonces
des manuels macron regarder était noire
de monde la gare montparnasse
il ya un autre truc qui a fait polémique
aussi c'était un reportage qui a été
diffusé dans sept à huit sur les
citadins et parisiens qui ont décidé de
quitter la ville et ce reportage a
choqué les internautes ils ont suivi une
famille qui a décidé d'aller survivre
phillies allait survivre en vendée
regardez ce qu'ils disent deux heures
avant l'entrée en vigueur du confinement
les trains sont bondés schaul à sa
compagne lucile et leurs deux filles ont
fait leurs valises le matin-même habite
à paris dans 45 avec deux adolescentes
et là c'est pas possible eh bien on
pouvoir la compagnie un jardin et où on
a un peu plus de place pour pouvoir
survivre avec leur fille lou andréas
saison et nora 13 ans elle quitte la
capitale
non sans une pointe de culpabilité c'est
chouette d'aller à la campagne mais
c'est surtout quitter paris dans ces
conditions là reste à part
voilà comme si on fuyait un peu c'est un
petit peu dérangeant en trois jours la
bombe et a vu débarquer des milliers de
parisiens rodez quand tu vois ça tu es
là tu comprends que ça ait pu choquer
les internautes c'est au pas oui
mais bien sûr parce que je comprends pas
il ya le confinement total mois depuis
lundi je suis là la voiture est devant
la maison de pain for kids roland c'est
une il faut il l'avouer peaufiner reste
est consigné
[ __ ] mais je le crois pas mon
nationaux mais je suis jamais à la
maison
jamie il ya toujours les journalistes
les matches de l'om les pattes et
j'écoutais je suis jamais pour que moi
je reste à la maison c'est config et les
offres parce qu'il y en a beaucoup qui
sortent là alors que les pasteurs du
temps y'en a marre que les sert à lutter
par les couilles il peut partir mais les
loups hélas aujourd'hui veut sortir il
va travailler il a ma gueule lic les
flics que les filles portent chapkas par
des drones yat il faut départ de la
police et des pompiers et a pu je suis
touché directement à moi parce que je
martyrs qui travaillent des hypers unis
par à aubagne en jeu la famille de
marcheurs ticket elle sur mineurs dans
les écouteurs marié du chien christian
premier cher donc la tnr vais pas me
dire que j'écope parier je suis un des
premiers touchés par ça parce que j'ai
de la famille qui va au contact et
qu'elle je pense que ma fille ma nièce
peu risqué sa vie parce que cette
terreur ils veulent continuer à pois
mais lequel à terre le redis ce qui
d'ailleurs de carrefour